you want divorce to be made illegal why
yes because I don't think what we have
today is really marriage What is
marriage it's For Better or For Worse
for richer for poorer and sickness and
in health till death do us part that's
what marriage is supposed to be but
feminists have ruined marriage for the
people that actually believe in marriage
when there is a 50 divorce rate and the
average man
I I didn't say that it was all down to
the women
you asked why I want divorce to be
banned can I finish yeah first so I'm
saying you know the people that believe
in divorce go be in long-term
relationships leave marriage for the
people that actually believe in For
Better or For Worse for richer for
poorer in sickness and in health till
death do us part